hi there steve kaufman here again um
language learning often gets involved
with politics it gets involved with
sports
um now we have the situation montreal
where the montreal canadiens or le
canadian
have a unilingual english-speaking coach
at least an interim coach because the
previous coach jacques martin who is
bilingual
was let go
and this has caused a great deal of
controversy in the french-speaking media
in in montreal
and uh they feel that the coach for the
montreal canadiens should be able to
speak in french where do i stand on this
you know and there's a lot of uh
commentary at least in the english
canadian media that it really shouldn't
matter that if he's a good coach then
all the fans will be happy as long as
the team wins and so forth
and we even had a discussion about it at
link in our forum and one of our members
ed
pointed out that um say if uh
a team in stockholm had a coach who
couldn't speak speak swedish nobody
would get upset
all of that is true however i very much
agree with the french speaking media
because professional sports is
entertainment
and every market is different
in sweden they are they don't expect
foreigners to speak swedish
there's no history of swedish swedish
having been sort of treated as a second
class language they haven't had to fight
for swedish language rights in sweden
so the whole political
environment and the situation in the
market and the expectations
of the consumers is quite different but
in montreal
it's a very sensitive subject
and
quite honestly in vancouver if we had a
unilingual french coach that would not
go down very well
i mean i follow the vancouver canucks
and every day or not every day but quite
often i go to their website and i watch
these little video interviews
typically the coach and the players have
nothing of interest to say
but we have a tendency to hang on to
their every word as if there was
substance there which there never is
it's always the same line they write the
script at the beginning of the year and
they all repeat it
but we want to hear these people say
something in a language that we can
understand so the swedish players we
have on our team when we had russians on
our team
checks whatever they all finns they can
all speak germans we've had they can all
speak english
uh and that's the language of the market
it's the same in golf i i some while ago
when there was this controversy over
whether the korean
uh the very successful korean women
golfers should be required to improve
their english and this was a request put
forward by
the lpga the ladies professional golfers
association and i said yes they should
they should have to they should this is
business
um of course i was i'm still they get
criticism on my youtube channel that i'm
a racist i'm a bigot and stuff like that
and to me it's it's just normal that's
it's business
when when they interview kj choi i don't
know if any of you follow golf but kj
choi who's a great golfer i love
watching him
he's got a very nice pleasant
decent manner and his english is
atrocious
but i love listening to him because it's
kj's voice it's him speaking
uh or trying to speak english and that's
far preferable to having
kj speak to an interpreter somebody
else's voice
and i remember some while ago there was
a fellow from argentina who won a major
golf uh tournament in the us and he said
well my golf speaks for itself and if i
play golf well that's all that matters
and now you shouldn't have to learn
english and uh he took all his
interviews in spanish well to my mind
he's a fool
because he's not helping out the whole
business model whereas other golfers
from spain from france from wherever
they come from japan
now kj for example in korea they will
try their best to say something in
english
now the coach getting back to the
montreal canadiens is the main
sort of contact point for the media
so yeah i would say that in the case of
the montreal canadiens with all the
tradition of their hockey teams which
used to be predominantly quebecois
french canadians and as now of course in
the in the new globalized nhl they could
be you know europeans or americans or
english canadians or anything else but
there is this tradition of lake nadia
you know
being
the team of the french canadians
so for that reason absolutely they
should have a coach who speaks french he
needn't be a franco
quebecois he can be anyone but who can
at least communicate in french and i
think the same would be true i'd be
curious to know if the coach of
the barcelona soccer teams
uh
speaks catalan
if he does if whoever he is if he
doesn't he should learn it
uh in order to communicate with the
people who pay his salaries so that's my
feeling on that and the the name of the
the interim coach who now looks like a
lame duck
cunningworth was it roger cunningworth
again we'd love to have him on link
uh they've got lots of time sitting in
airplanes and traveling around it
wouldn't take him very long
to uh to get to a level where he could
uh he could answer some questions
and uh and the emphasis should be
initially on understanding the language
uh
just so that there's so some sense that
he communicating uh with his marketplace
so that's my take on that yes the
montreal canadiens deserve a coach who
speaks french uh
professional sports is entertainment uh
it makes sense that i mean it's a
continuum and i see what the canucks do
here in vancouver they're forever
involved with the community they are
either out at some charity event or
they're at some fundraiser or there's a
dinner with supporters and they all
speak english because vancouver's an
english-speaking city and it seems to me
that the fans and supporters in montreal
have the right to the same
kind of entertainment and their
interaction with their stars in french
so there you have it thank you for
listening